well here in germany the country's
foreign minister has denounced an attack
on a student
outside a synagogue in the northern city
of hamburg heiko moss condemned the
incident as
anti-semitic police say a man dressed in
military-style clothing
hit the victim over the head with a
shovel security forces overpowered the
assailant the attack revives memories of
an assault on a synagogue
in the eastern city of hala a year ago
earlier we spoke with our political
correspondent nina hasa she sent us
this report according to media reports
the 29 year old german
attacked the 26 year old victim when the
man tried to enter the synagogue
premises he hit the jewish student on
the head with a shovel
and that caused severe head injuries
that are not life-threatening however
said the police the attacker was
overpowered by security forces and those
security forces are always present
on jewish institutions grounds here in
germany
and the victim has been taken to
hospital the police have yet to comment
on the motive of this deed and the
attack is now being investigated by
german authorities
a reliable german news agency dpa
reports that the attacker was wearing
military clothing
and that he was carrying a note with a
swastika in his trouser pockets
which is of course a clear indication
that this might well have been
an anti-semitic attack and another hint
for that theory
is that this attack happened on sukkot
which is one of judaism's most important
holidays